greetings Nephilim and welcome to the
patch to 600 overview today we're going
to talk about the new features and
additions coming to both Reaper of souls
and the ultimate evil edition of diablo
3 our latest hero class is raring to go
so let's not keep him waiting a
[Music]
completely new feature is coming in the
form of challenge rift a special type of
Nephilim rift
challenge rifts offer the unique
experience test drive and other players
fills and gear each week a new
challenger could be made available a
completely static experience they offer
a very different way to play diablo 3
testing your memory and game mastery to
rightfully claim your spot at the top of
the leaderboards even if you're not the
competing types you can claim a bundle
of loot once a week by simply beating
the original runner's time if you'd like
more information be sure to check our
other video on challengers for the full
details
the shrouded moors have long since been
abandoned by any civilized inhabitant
ferocious beasts scavenge forever pray
they find and a long-forgotten evil
lurks below the fetid swamps will you
thwart the brutal cultists and twisted
Horrors they have created explore the
shrouded Moors in the temple of the
firstborn in act 2 now available in
adventure mode after the battle between
the Nephilim and Diablo in the high
heavens unintended consequences it
caused explorable tears to appear across
the skies these realms of fate stitched
together the various experiences of
Nephilim heroes and seamless transition
resulting in completely variable
environments and most importantly new
places to slay monsters and get loot for
new realms of fate are available in act
4 adventure mode with plenty of new
bounties for the intrepid adventurer to
complete one more thing Nephilim the
necromancer class is ready to join the
fight for sanctuary surviving the rise
of the necromancer pack is now available
for purchase directly through a new
store interface in the diablo 5 the
necromancer is a delightfully dark new
addition to the diablo 3 family and
features spells that master the elements
of blood bone and decay
explore the campaign with all new dialog
or jump into adventure mode and gear
yourself out with dozens of new
legendary items and four new class sets
in addition the rise of the necromancer
pack also includes new cosmetics
including wings a pet a pennant and new
banner designs it also includes two new
character slots and two more stash tabs
so you'll have plenty of room to add
this commander of the Dead to your
collection patch to 6 oh and the
necromancer pack are available now for
more information about the latest patch
or the rise of the necromancer pack at
over to Diablo 3 comm if you are patch
notes and vlogs with all the details
that's all we have for you today so
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
sanctuary
[Music]